>> The question is can or will India become
a superpower?
And if so, by when?
I believe that none of us have a crystal ball.
Second, you know, different people have different
definitions of what a
superpower is.
So as I'm concerned, yes, maybe in about 15
or 20 years' time, not
overnight, we need work to be done.
India will become a superpower, but I'm referring
more to two types of
considerations which make a country a super
one.
We'll never be a military superpower.
We have no desire to be a military superpower.
We just need enough defensive capabilities
to defend us against
somebody we fear with an evil design on us.
But we will become a economic superpower because
of our large
hard-working and entrepreneurial people whether
in the field of
agriculture or industry or in the service
sector.
And also what is very important, I think as
well, apart from becoming
an economic superpower which will require
a great deal of effort and
work for the Indian people.
It's the Indian people which will make the
country a superpower not
just the government.
But government is important it has to add
value, provide contusive
environment for business to function.
But, unless we're economically strong, you
see, nobody in the world
listens to you.
So that is important.
But in addition to that, I think, India should
also become a kind of
place -- and over the last 20 or 30 years,
people get trained, get
educated in IIT or IIM's and then go abroad
to work.
There's nothing wrong with that.
They earn a lot of money.
They send some of the money back home.
They create a good reputation for India.
But now that's starting to changing a little
bit and they are returning
to work in India because there are tremendous
opportunities in India.
In that context, I think 20 years down the
line, I would like India to
become a place where not only are Indians,
maybe some other people from
other countries would like to come and work
here or even live here,
presuming we take care of our environment,
we take care of our
infrastructure, and we create conditions which
would make them happy
and proud to work in India.
An India where, for example, a child meeting
the top class education,
if he is competent, doesn't have to the depend
only on his parents'
income.
He should be able to have the kind of education
he wants, whether IIT
or IIM or what have you based on his capability.
And he should be able to have -- get a scholarship
or et cetera if his
parents can't afford to send him to a top
school.
So I think that's the kind of place India
would become, but the other
countries are also racing to become or remain
a superpower whether the
United States, China, Germany, Japan, or France.
But I think we have a good chance because
of our population and we need
to train them, educate them, and provide them
vocational training.
Once we do that, I know that we shall become
economic superpower.
But I must have this warning, if we in our
government do not take
advantage of our demographic dividend, do
not provide the right kind of
education and skills to our large population,
you know, maybe we have
200 million qualified graduates in two years
time, if we don't do that
then we have a problem.
But yes, a lot of great things are happening
and good luck to India.
All the best.